Cris Collinsworth part of Sunday Night
Football this Sunday night
it'll be Chris with Al Michaels Michele
Tafoya the Packers and the Niners Chris
also part of the NFL Network's NFL 100
show with Rich Eisen and Bill Belichick
and Chris kind enough to join us Chris
thanks for joining us I assume that
you're knee-deep in game footage of the
49ers and the Packers
I like the Niners I don't love the
Niners and it's because of Jimmy
Garoppolo I'm just not sure yet what
have you seen from Garoppolo yeah he's
made a few mistakes along the way and
he's a little bit of a finesse thrower I
didn't really realize that until I
started watching the tape he's he kind
of loves throwing the the lob balls in
over the top and and just sort of I you
know it's not one of those you sit there
and your watch the tape and go wow look
at that throw and you know who that
thing just comes rocketing out of his
hands but he's really good at reading
the defense's he has a great feel for
what they're doing but sometimes tries
to get a little too cute and it's cost
them a few interceptions this year any
questions about the Packers the Packers
actually impressed me a little bit more
their ability to run the ball especially
against Carolina was something you know
they've got two bags that can go they
rebuilt this offensive line it
defensively they made some big mistakes
in that last game but offensively you
know every once while you see a team
late in the year and you go alright
which one of these teams might be able
to go a little bit of a run here which
one of them kind of is sitting there and
remember this is a new offense there
they're just starting to get it figured
out if you remember the Rams and back to
their day that those type formations and
the play-action and the deep overs and
you know the ability to run the ball
with power inside zone or any of those
different things so I I kind of have a
little feeling on the Green Bay Packers
right now I have a little feeling that
that maybe we're just
starting to see what they're gonna
become playoff time can you read between
the lines with what Tom Brady is saying
about the offense or lack thereof what
you know I know there's frustration they
usually keep everything in in-house is
there something that we're missing with
what Brady is saying here he gave us a
line that was the most unbelievable line
that we never put on television I can't
believe we didn't put it on his opening
line was I have to be the the most
miserable eighth note quarterback in
history of the league and I somehow we
didn't get that out I have no idea why
we didn't I think they're so used to
just dominating and I think they're so
used to being able to do anything that
they want to do and and they don't
really appear to have that that sort of
game breaker on offense the way that
they have in the past you know at least
Gronk you knew you're going to get some
ability to be able to take the thing and
go down the field whether you know
Dorsett gives them a little bit of that
feel and you know they trade force anew
but there's not that guy that you just
sit there and go oh man I guy he scares
me to death out there Edelman is of
course a great player but and then when
they don't have that down the field kind
of threat working the running game
doesn't look quite as good so I think
it's a little bit of a mix of everything
but if you go right down to it the one
that's probably hurt him the most was
you know losing David Andrews on the
offensive line
losing Isaiah Wynn and now I guess he's
coming back at this point over Marshall
Newhouse but even in that game against
the Ravens that we saw them you know
when push really came to shove and they
got behind in the game they go into that
no huddle mode and I mean it is paper
speed mode and they're still flying up
and down the field and still had a
chance to win that game so I think
they're going to be ok the defense is
fantastic the secondary in particular is
just fantastic
so they'll do what they always do though
they'll hit a little wall
then they'll little takeoff in the
playoffs again do you look at the
Patriots game plan is still stopping
Ezekiel Elliott or have the Cowboys
become a passing team the pass first
than a run second team yeah that's a
good question i dak Prescott here in the
last few weeks has just been that other
guy you know I he's the one that you'd
say if you're if you're his agent this
is a dream scenario right now I mean
this is off the charts because you're
trying to get paid and dak let's start
with who he is as a person
dak is is the face of the Cowboys in the
same way that that Jason Witten and and
you know Tony Romo and some of the
superstars of that day I mean that guy
has a presence to him that is sort of
second to none we interview all these
quarterbacks so that part of the games
he definitely did and now with the way
that he's throwing the ball in the way
that he's understanding the game I think
that he's spent a lot of time on that
throwing motion you know we saw the what
was the that was it a being right I get
all my internet words mixed up you know
but you know the thing where they put
together and he's doing his hips the
thing we had on before the game and he's
flying the hips out and all that stuff
and so the best of these guys now are
really not having to step into their
throws I think you'll see it with
Garoppolo this week as well dak Prescott
is sort of the ultimate of that he never
takes a step with that front foot it is
just pure hips and firing the ball and
being able to do it and if Amari Cooper
stays healthy I think Amari Cooper has
been the key to that offense really
since the beginning the minute he came
over from Oakland that was a different
team it was a different offense and dak
Prescott was a different quarterback dak
Prescott right now to me the Cowboys are
going to be lucky to get him for 40
minutes I've been so high on the Cowboys
from the start of the season I really
thought that they they could go to the
Super Bowl this year
what did I miss with the couple I know
they can still go but are they missing
something I still think they could go
I really do I there is no reason
honestly that this team should not be
that good and and you go back to the
games where they get beat and you just
start going how did they lose that game
right I mean you just you know how was
it that they lost that but across the
board
I mean main linebackers that can play
the way that their linebackers can play
I mean Jaylon Smith Layton Vander Ashe
Shawn Lee is a backup Joe Thomas and in
past coverage situations they have great
pass rushers and Clin and Lawrence on
the outside I think good enough and the
secondary Jordan Lewis has kind of added
a little element to that to end in the
slot in there he's been a tremendous
player so what is it about their defense
that you go ok that's not good and on
offense my god they got arguably the
best offensive line the best running
back one of the top five receivers in
the game and dak Prescott red-hot so
what is it that's keeping these guys
from winning a championship and I cannot
I can't put my finger on it other than
the fact that they've lost a bunch of
close games and and they're know locked
I mean they were going to have to win
the division likely to even get into
playoffs here so either Philadelphia
Dallas and all likelihood or so you know
he's Chris Collinsworth Sunday Night
Football it'll be the Niners
against the Green Bay Packers I know
this was unintentional it feels like the
new pass interference replay rule has
actually helped the defense because if
I'm a defensive coordinator I just I
just say to my guys go out and grab and
hold and clutch and whatever you got to
do they're not going to call it yeah
it's such a mess I mean really I
understand the frustration of everybody
at New Orleans over that play last year
and you know yeah we wanted to replay to
to cure all the evils of the world and I
was the biggest proponent of instant
replay I mean trust me I've been
in this and I even pushed it for pass
interference but I think the thing that
I missed in the whole thing is that at
the end of the day this is a show you
know and maybe I'm a little more
sensitive to it being on television but
at the end of the day this is the show
and and what we want is a great show and
in a great movie you are in a great
Broadway play there comes a point in
that Broadway play where you get
immersed in it right where you start to
really live that play or that movie
and if 17 times during a Broadway play
they shut it down because they wanted to
go back and make sure they got that
scene right well it wouldn't have much
magic to it anymore you know and I think
that the NFL is in danger just a little
bit of having that happen to them that
just about the time that is a fan or as
a viewer as a broadcaster that I'm all
in right here we go man if we're in the
last two minutes and we're going down
the field and guys are making great
plays and these phenomenal athletes out
there on the field and all of a sudden
I'm spending the next two minutes
looking at a guy in a baseball hat
looking at a Microsoft Surface tablet
and I don't know why he's looking at it
he's not making the call anyway somebody
in New York's making a call and I I
don't like it anymore I mean honestly if
they if they did away with replay
tomorrow I think I would be just fine
with it
yeah I'm right there with you I said
either use it use it correctly or don't
use it at all I'll leave you with this
Chris Eric Weddle spent three years with
the Baltimore Ravens he now plays for
the Rams the Rams play the Ravens Eric
Weddle is on record saying I could tell
them a lot of stuff but that's not just
who I am so he doesn't want to tell his
new team about the Ravens I have a lot
of respect for that place not only how
it helped my career and rejuvenated my
career but how they treated myself and
my family but in a tight-knit group and
what I would be what kind of man would I
be if I turned my back on all of them
what do you make of Eric Weddle not
wanting to share secrets with his new
team about his old team
I get it I understand who he is as a guy
let me just say that he's a great guy
but by not giving your team an advantage
you're giving your team a disadvantage
Chris every other sucker in this league
is giving it up I mean they're telling
everything they know in trying to help
their new team win a game so I think
that it's not a net neutral kind of
situation you're actually making it a
disadvantage for your new team that make
sense yeah it does make sense I just
don't understand it you know your job
some did the Ravens turn their back on
Eric Weddle and then he ended up with
the Rams did he turn his back on the
Ravens and then ended up with the Rams
but you're with the Rams
you know help them it's your job to win
I mean no matter how it is that you did
to that point I in this day and age
anybody that reflects any part of a
little bit of integrity I kind of have
some admiration for even if I don't
encounter person agree with it so I'm
trying to back off and there's a little
bouquet no but I know but I understand I
understand him but I disagree with the
premise I do disagree thank you Chris
great to catch up with you will be
watching Sunday night thank you
I bought a good target it's Chris
Collinsworth NBC Sunday Night Football
and a majority owner in pro Football
Focus it'll be the Packers and Niners
coming up on Sunday night for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
Live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]